hey you guys it's Easter Sunday although
I didn't realize that day well yeah I
didn't know it was coming and then I
guess cuz I'm not like a kid anymore so
I don't get like a cool Easter basket
with a bunch of chocolate and stuff in
it yeah cuz that was not only because
you know I wasn't raised religious so we
didn't spend celebrating like a
religious holiday which is candy holiday
yeah
so since I don't get any candy I didn't
realize it was Easter it's got a whole
jar candy out there you want it okay
well yeah that's the thing it's just
like I thought of it because my mom sent
me an email was like oh happy Easter
like what are you guys making it all
about like I was like we made to
Hawaiian pizza yeah
which that's kind of funny because we
had been talking I don't even remember
how we got on the topic as most of the
topics that we talked about but so we're
sidetracked yeah but where we talked
about Hawaiian pizza and I was saying
yeah I even like pineapple on pizza
fight me and so then I guess we talked
about it and then like the next day
sounds like man one Pizza sounds kind of
good it's like we got a ham but however
we did not have any pineapple no
scythe-like and I went I went Omega Man
on out there to try to go get pineapple
baby public public's and public's had a
damn line going all the way down the
side of it cuz they're only letting so
many people in it and I needed one can
some psycho [ __ ] across the street was a
Walgreens and I said maybe by a chance
they might have because they do have
some campfire but say they have some
canned stuff there so I go over there
and I'm looking dope coke cans and then
I saw a little thing I like peach you
know at peach there's not peach but with
a cocktail that fruit [ __ ] yeah for a
cocktail sup and next to it a big empty
space and I said five and I looked down
in that empty space you know it's down
one of the bottom shells I looked down
at that empty space and then the back
was [ __ ] one one pie what if I he was
two for two dollars in my head one came
back I was cradling that [ __ ] yeah and
[ __ ] Walgreens it was the last one yes
everybody up there what Jesus wanted us
to have a wine pizza yeah not enough to
make two pieces pretty sir pika
yeah cuz we made one yes
anyway yes they made ones a day today I
did damn pan pizza did it in the
cast-iron skillet yeah it's good either
way it's good either way I mean honestly
it's very bready so it's like I can't
really eat anything all right today but
you know that's what I mean it's like
that's why even if I had at Easter
basket full of candy I would feel really
bad about eating it I was like I like
the white chocolate bunnies that's how
you always knew it was my Easter basket
because everybody else is like white
chocolate gross like all my siblings and
stuff but my grandma was super Cola and
she knew that I liked white chocolate
better than anything I mean it's like
any of those books so she always like
got me got me a white chocolate bunny
when I was a kid those little bunnies
were a sign of [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
gonna be bad well it's what kind of
bunnies you get like Palmer is you know
the Palmer brand ones which is you know
that you only mainly see that around
Easter time those are terrible yeah
there's only ones that kind of they're
Hollow yeah it was like it's like eating
wax but and it was it just didn't have a
chocolate flavor just was sweet
I don't think um honestly from what I
could determine I don't know and I don't
know if this is the case but I have
heard that Palmer's chocolate bunnies
you're not they're not legally allowed
to call them a chocolate bunny or milk
chocolate because it doesn't have enough
cocoa fat or a nut butter fat or
whatever you know what I mean because
you have to have like a certain
percentage of all that stuff so I think
they are just like chocolate you have to
call the chocolate flavor
you can't call yeah those are the ones I
mostly remember yeah that's like the
cheapest guy didn't need them don't get
like a sense of seven of them yeah cuz
relatives have give them to you now but
now and then you get one that was solid
yeah those were good that's what I
that's what I have my grandma always got
me like the white chocolate could get it
all in one day I don't know who made it
I don't remember it was like Whitman's
or what's that other one that starts
with the r I can't remember it wasn't
Palmer though came in a box with a clear
yeah yeah yeah member and they were
heavy yeah they weren't his thick but
they were solid they were probably about
yeah 3/4 of an inch thick something like
that they were probably about you know
nine inches tall yeah yeah that's what I
always got I always got a white
chocolate one like that there was maybe
this Russell Stover might be Russell
Stover because which is like a step up
yeah step up from [ __ ] Palmer cuz
like I said Palmer is like kind of like
the [ __ ] that was like the [ __ ]
she dressed
chocolate and then we have like one
Cadbury
in there you can't really eat more than
one of those because they're so like
sweet you know like get all those too
you know yeah it's kinda like a fake
Christmas there'd be a lot of stuff and
some issues yes filler well so and
sometimes she get like little toys and
[ __ ] like that you know what I mean it
was mostly candy but yeah you know my
grandma she's like super awesome and she
used to go all out like for all the kids
and I have like a lot of I had a lot of
siblings and a lot of cousins so she
would get like a big basket for
everybody with like with specific stuff
that everybody liked him they'd try to
give me all that chocolate I didn't like
that [ __ ] man I wanted [ __ ] like zot zot
sand pop rocks and for O'Fallon caps and
[ __ ] I like the real Jolly Ranchers
he likes fruity edge fruity candy yeah I
was like Jolly Ranchers but as a whole I
won't turn down like fruity candy but if
I am picking a candy I usually always
pick something chocolate or something
with nuts in it or something with mint
yeah we saw a decent movie last night it
was it was kind of like a throwback
movie felt like I was watching a really
good old fashioned um [ __ ]
what's that drunk John Carver yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] names always [ __ ] looming
I like watching a really good John
Carpenter movie and it was called VFW
yeah it's good even had a John Carpenter
style soundtrack to it it sounded like
carpenter playing it really did it's
like and if you had have had that kind
of throwback low-budget house next to it
low budget movie done excellently had
good practical effects it was kind of
like kind of like kind of like assault
on precinct 13 mixed with mixed with
this came from New York and maybe like a
lit kinda tone was like the fog yeah or
the vision it had like a lot of like
over-the-top gore not overtime gore yeah
I mean we're gonna be doing like then
we're gonna do a full review we're gonna
do a full review on the next matinee
show um you know what I mean so I saw
he's been watching them like over the
week
I got it off an xbox standard standard
definition I think it was 399 yeah on
standard definition the thing is is it
looked good in standard definition
because they're trying to make it look
like
was shot on old film yeah yeah no I
called 16-millimeter yeah that's a like
kind of grotty looking it's trying to
trying to take you back to like 83 or
something and I think they pulled that
up successfully yeah go rented it's good
yeah it's a it was a hell of a lot of
fun I thought it's got like a lot of
like really good actors in it yeah it's
got the dude that played Scully from
from command command oh yeah he's in it
it's got that black dude that I think
Fred Williams the fred williamson i he
played in a lot of stuff he was in a lot
of black spots yeah yeah he's in it um
had the dude from Cheers
yeah George Wendt yeah he's been in a
lot of horror lately right well not
lately but over the last 20 years or so
then it had a couple of the cool guys
and I don't really recognize I had the
the dude that the dude that played in
Karate Kid the Blatt the bad guy at the
bad guy the guy who was a joker Brokaw
he was in it and then who's still on
Cobra Kai yeah show yeah that's a really
good to see soon I mean it might have
gotten like delayed because I don't know
if they're still like filming [ __ ] Cobra
Kai was excellent yeah I really liked I
really got better as it went that was
like that we we actually I'd like to see
that again yeah we actually upgraded to
like you know the higher echelon YouTube
just so we just watch as it was a
youtube original yeah it's good yeah
it's excellent and it's like I'm that's
company I liked like The Karate Kid like
the first movie the other ones were done
but the LR 2 is kind of dug but the
first one is an epic iconic movie
especially if you were a kid you saw in
that era yeah you know back when people
weren't sure who didn't know about fake
dojos and you know McDo joes and [ __ ]
fake martial arts and [ __ ] oh and
[ __ ] we don't know but you know and it's
karate
it's a karate movie yeah you could fight
with karate you'd get your ass whipped
against a [ __ ] equal or better
fighter who's doing MMA but if you just
have to do it just untrained [ __ ]
bullies sometimes karate could work but
you had to become a badass somebody
there's a lot of [ __ ] they're not
telling you it's not
just karate alone it's also weight
training and [ __ ] diet and learning
how to take a beatin you know there's a
lot of [ __ ] involved I feel like bitin
you know I feel like in fighting that is
one of the like least talked about
aspects but sometimes I think is the
most important thing is learning to like
your active eating and not [ __ ]
really getting upset and just yeah and
just like get back up and [ __ ] like that
cuz that's like a big part of yeah fight
we shake and abuse we used to get in
fights in the [ __ ] army and we would
we try to beat each other up but we were
afraid of leaving like serious bruises
Yona vain because you could get in
trouble you get an article 15 for
fighting yeah
so you had to fight without doing a
whole lot of damage to the guy's face
you'll get in trouble but you just
learned from that experience on how to
[ __ ] take a beating yeah and we used
to get into fights to where you know
neither neither guy won you just got
[ __ ] tired yeah body blows and stuff
snaps you'd hit the dude but you hit him
in the side of the head you know I mean
try to keep him from getting a black eye
you know and you just suck it in in it
it's like a [ __ ] workout man you're
like 15 minutes into that [ __ ] felt like
you've been doing it kicking in [ __ ] you
know you'd be all [ __ ] up you had to
run in the morning and [ __ ] you know
you're too limp in like why did we do
that
well no you knew exactly why it was
serious at the time it's just you're
trying to you put a bunch of [ __ ]
alpha males and Sigma males together
it's gonna be a [ __ ] pissing match
the the infantry the army infantry is
the ultimate oh not the ultimate but
it's entry level tough man competition
yeah ultimate tough man competitions
[ __ ] like SF OD or you know [ __ ]
Special Forces and Ranger Ranger [ __ ]
in the army [ __ ] tough and hard you
know just the sleep deprivation alone
they're not fighting each other you're
just fighting yourself yeah because
you're trying to
tell your body to do things that's just
not supposed to be doing yeah you know
no sane person would be doing the [ __ ]
that you have to do to get through
Ranger School you know it's just sleep
and food deprivation and just nothing
but doing patrols over and over again
and [ __ ] grass drills and smoking
smoking yourself and pops did a really
good series of telling about how he went
through do you go on [ __ ] shoot go
[ __ ] find a channel called
redonkulous and that's Pop's channel
he's ex-special forces and x infantry
and X Ranger and he'll tell you about
all those schools and [ __ ] it's like
volunteering to go to Auschwitz was like
I believe it yeah
especially back in those days I don't
know if they [ __ ] made it easy you
know which there he'll talk about that
too because it looks like they made it a
little bit easier the and he knew who
else was a badass Ranger like people
don't know this James Earl Jones Darth
Vader was a [ __ ] Ranger yeah yeah and
note how he doesn't go around telling
everybody because I bet you guys didn't
even know that I didn't even know that
but he's a [ __ ] Ranger yeah see and
that's why that's what we were talking
about the other day it's like people
that are actually really Rangers Ray's
not talking about it don't go around
having to tell everybody yeah trying to
like use it to pick up women at bars
yeah now Rangers understand human
limitations yeah cuz you constantly
battle it against human limitations yeah
like you kind of been to the ends of the
earth and come back yeah and it's all
really the body's part of it but also
it's basically its willpower yeah
unlimited willpower but there's you know
what held me back from it was swim test
I just simply just could not pass that
[ __ ] swim test which is swim down to
the bottom of pool and get that rucksack
and swim back up with it yeah anyway
what [ __ ] before the water got into it
I think it was about 40 pounds yeah and
you're doing this in full uniform with
your rifle and your helmet off yeah
least it was back then they throw it
into the deep side of the pool swim test
like I'm a good swimmer but yeah that's
that's a whole
wasn't Ranger school that was uh that
pretty Ranger the thing that was leading
out these leads up to it
right but yeah I could I can see how
that would knock a lot of you well cuz
very very few people could probably even
get a shot at ran your school you had to
press this little pre Ranger course to
show your chanted command that you were
worthy of at least being sent to the
school right but what was funny is that
you know the actual school they'd have
dudes from [ __ ] you know clerks from
you know people from [ __ ] water
purification specialists they'd be
sending their guys to it and immediately
get kicked back yeah cuz it's on the
first day of [ __ ] Ranger school
[ __ ] about it seventy percent of them
would just [ __ ] it I can't take it
because they do all the hardship first
to let everybody out waste their time
what it was is that the unit's infantry
units good ones didn't want to be
embarrassed or dishonored by having
anybody that sent that had a that had no
chance yeah you know I mean they they
were like well we're gonna send you to
Ranger School we want you to at least be
able to [ __ ] put up with it for a
month yeah not that [ __ ] where you yeah
like I said otherwise it'd be like a
waste of time into wasting time and
money it's also dishonorable yeah
because then you're failing alongside
some water purification specialist yeah
you guys don't understand the [ __ ]
rivalry within the are not only is it
what between units it's inside units
like a [ __ ] alpha copy because I'm going
to half a company I stand right here and
Charlie Company [ __ ] those [ __ ] Shane
[ __ ] [ __ ] wimps well you know yeah so
I guess that's probably all that we're
gonna talk no I want to mention I want
to mention the thing is about China
China's [ __ ] abuse of black Africans
right now you guys have been sending me
videos subscribers been like this video
videos of them [ __ ] kicking black
people down the street and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] they got signs up even on
McDonald's print in English if you're
black don't come in here you know for
health reasons to [ __ ] basically what
happened is is that Chinese are saying
that they didn't [ __ ] spread Kove it
had nothing to do with their wet marks
it
black people ain't that something
started off first it was Japanese did it
alright that's it yeah that's as I worst
thing nice that's what I would have
suspect that didn't pan out and they
said American army did it because there
was a couple of American army guys down
there at the time that the [ __ ] America
and now they're gonna [ __ ] we didn't
do it the black people did it ain't that
some [ __ ] this is the thing like I said
and we were talking about this the other
day about how I was actually surprised
at how most people seem to be like
handling this pretty well which I didn't
suspect however there's always going to
be a contingent of people especially
something like this nah dude I know well
especially something like this it's
affecting the whole entire world and is
not really controllable by any person
like its larger than any one person or
group available so you're always gonna
get people you know in uncertain
situations who are going to be looking
for a scapegoat
yeah and inés blaming everybody but
China and they're not but it has nothing
to do with the thing is it's like Brian
dogs alive and viruses are like no one's
not necessarily anyone's fault
they just happen well in the Chinese
mind it is yeah I mean if [ __ ] they're
saying that we're not dirty
you know the black people are dirty so
this shit's [ __ ] going bad ban [ __ ]
these people are these people are
[ __ ] ma'am remember that looking guy
in Hong Kong he became a meme he's that
Hong Kong guy he's got the [ __ ] mask
on because China is [ __ ] you say oh
yeah that's why China is [ __ ] he had
it right China is [ __ ] looking funny
yes and then and now China's got all of
its suck in Chinese owned all the
Chinese own [ __ ] news stations are
saying that you know well this has been
going on for weeks that China didn't do
it you know you could tell who works
which one of these you know all these
news channels most of them are owned by
China you can tell you can tell which
ones are Chinese owned they won't say
anything bad about China go to talk
about China's bad you're a racist menace
China is China [ __ ] paying them to
say that they'll lose their job if they
talk bad about China well like I said
especially do the same thing with those
second
football basketball players remember
that they couldn't say anything bad
about China we're not saying benefit
because they own all those [ __ ] ball
teams we need to [ __ ] break off
that's it's a fascist country
all right it's a fascist communist
country and it's very racist you know
you don't believe me just have you go go
on serpent za the YouTube channel he
lived there he married a Chinese woman
you know he likes the Chinese people and
you know he you know he's he his wife
had to leave and racism had a lot to do
that he's a white guy and it's just they
just they they they think that they're
better than everybody else in the [ __ ]
world but their government tells him
that same thing that the same thing that
German government told the Germans back
in World War two that same [ __ ] I spoken
my piece about well you know and like I
said it's the whole thing is stupid
because a virus isn't caused by anybody
necessarily they just happen yeah but in
China's from China in the Maya Chinese
nationalists and Chinese
ultra-nationalist is is that they are
impure there that they are totally pure
and there's no way any disease could
spring from anything that they did yeah
and you know I just saw videos of dudes
frying dogs alive and then with meat
cleavers cutting one dog apart and then
other dogs in the cage right next to it
watching it happen and I was like man
these dudes are [ __ ] inhuman man I
couldn't do that I just couldn't do that
yeah you know you got to have some kind
of an empathy you know even for things
that aren't aren't human yeah and I'm in
dogs and cats and even wild animals and
you know I'm a hunter I hunt deer but
I'm not cutting a living deer apart you
know just a single shot you know it
kills it nearly instantly you know I
just I just can't torture an animal you
know because because it tastes better
that's what they say I mean well it
makes it taste better and I just I
turned on them you know turned on yeah
and you know and and it's not just you
know that's racist [ __ ] the Koreans
didn't do that the Koreans would be you
know their hair would stand on the back
of their hands is you don't do that to
an animal the Japanese wouldn't do that
they might cut a living fish apart but
that's pretty you know
so she but a fish is pretty damn
primitive you know that's not the same
as a [ __ ] dog yeah like a mammal yeah
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] up fish is
just a couple steps above a bug really
yeah there's not much to although to be
honest I would even I've done it before
cuz I used to go fishing a lot with my
family when I was younger and I've cut a
part of living fish before but I even
felt bad doing that yeah I [ __ ] feel
bad stepping on a bug even accidentally
now does this up a cockroach those
things like you know squid and octopus
stuff like that I couldn't cut that
alive no there's no tellin ya and they
have a lot of sensory stuff in them you
know I saw this one japanese girl she
was pulling a damn mantel off a [ __ ]
live and not a living squid net squid
because that [ __ ] hurt you know the
main and I just yes they have like well
don't they have like sensory organs like
all the place rain is like oh yeah their
brain is your whole body yeah yeah I
mean so I got no problem with you eating
these animals but they've got to be
humanely slaughtered yeah you know so as
quickly as possible
I mean yeah they don't like no stop or
even know what's going on right I would
most people would prefer that right
but yeah so anyway I guess have a good
rest of your Easter I shoulda like got
Pookie in here and put some little bunny
ears on it's like that you should sleep
she's wrapped up around that you know
that little wand that has the dam yeah
she has this little it's like a little
clear wand that it has like this long
like fabric fabric yes zebra skin or
something like that it's got a bell on
the end of it she likes to chase it yeah
and she's she was playing with it you
know I mean she fell asleep not threw it
to her
I had it all wrapped up and she [ __ ]
grabbed it like that went back to sleep
so she's sleeping in there with her
little like little long yeah like laid
in her bed yes you got it oh she's so
cute
yeah all right so yeah have a good rest
are your Sunday in your Easter Sunday if
you're celebrating that and we'll talk
to you guys again tomorrow